Hi, I'm Eli Roth
with Fandango MOVIECLIPS.
Here's some things to know before you
go for my new film The Green Inferno.
(SCREAMING)
The Green Inferno is about a bunch
of students from New York city that
decide they're going to go
and save the Amazon and they're going
to stop construction to protect
the last uncontacted tribe.
They save the tribe and on
the way home, their plane crashes
and the villagers think
they're intruders
and dart them and take them
to the village, and they--
Kids become their food supply.
The Green Inferno is filmed
in a village that is completely
cut off from society.
We had to conceptually explain to
this village what a movie was.
How do we do that?
The Peruvian producers gathered
the whole village around and said
we're gonna show you a movie
called Cannibal Holocaust.
This is the single most
violent film ever made.
Luckily, the village thought it was
a comedy, all 300 villagers voted and
they agreed to let us shoot there.
-(SHOUTING)
-(DRUMS BEATING)
Now, these people had
never acted before,
so we had to explain to them
action, cut. The kids loved it.
They loved picking up the parts
of the dead bodies.
Everybody wanted to be
covered in blood.
Everybody wanted to eat somebody.
They all thought it was hilarious.
They thought we were making a comedy,
and they were amazing actors.
Imagine someone with no awareness
of the camera,
no frame of reference for
what it's like to be photographed.
So, they were amazing.
They were some of the best actors
I've ever worked with.
The kids in the movie really,
really got into it.
They caught a baby python.
They thought it'd be funny if when
the Americans were in the cage,
you threw a live snake at them.
That's actually a great idea!
We were shooting in Chile where the
safety laws are a little different
the actors, Kirby and Magda,
looked at me and go,
"Wait, is that thing poisonous?"
We go "No, no, no, it's a python,
don't worry."
I'm hiding behind the camera
and go "Action! Acción!" and the kids
are just like dangling, slapping
these girls in the face with
a python and if you freeze frame it,
the snake is like--
(HISSING)
And its teeth are out literally
an inch from their eyeballs.
The Green Inferno is inspired by
Occupy Wall Street.
It's about kids that latch on
to causes that they don't know
everything about or don't believe in
or latch onto it because it's trendy.
I kept noticing hashtag of the week.
It's everyone going
"How can you not care!"
Kony 2012, Child Soldiers in Uganda.
You get the feeling that now there
are these social justice warriors
out there to make you feel bad
about everything.
Social activism can be great.
It can be this amazing
vehicle for change,
but so many people, I feel, doing it
not because they believe
in the cause, but want
to look like they care.
They love being on
the home page of Reddit.
I want to see kids like that
just get eaten, eyeballs torn out,
get their tongues sliced off,
genitals mutilated.
I want full-on cannibal gore.
That for me is hilarious.
So, Green Inferno is
a terrifying movie,
but in a very perverse way,
it's fun to watch
these kids get it.
(SCREAMING)
I'm Eli Roth
for Fandango MOVIECLIPS.
Thanks for watching
and check out The Green Inferno.
September 25th.
Can you take the heat?